a new display of u.s resolve in the push
to help ukraine in the war against
russia house speaker nancy pelosi is
leading a congressional delegation in
poland today after a surprise trip over
the weekend to kiev and a meeting with
ukrainian president vladimir zelinski
stands with ukraine
we stand with ukraine until victory is
won
of course there are questions about what
victory would actually look like in the
face of russia's unrelenting assault
especially in eastern ukraine while the
u.s delegation visited keefe dozens of
civilian survivors of the siege of
mariupol finally emerged from a besieged
steel plant in that area many others
though are still believed to be trapped
inside along with ukrainian soldiers
charlie dagetta is once again in ukraine
for us charlie good morning a busy
weekend
good morning to you tony yes this is
what's left of an industrial site after
the russian military found out that
ukrainian forces were using it as a base
they're now closing in on three sides
meanwhile the evacuation of that steel
plant has resumed today
from beneath the rubble and remains of
the pummeled steelworks plant day's
survivors emerged to the light of day
i can't believe it two months of
darkness said natalya used manova we did
not see any sunlight we were so scared
families many children even pets among
those now headed toward the relative
safety of ukrainian-held territory their
rescue after so many failed attempts
marks a significant achievement for both
the u.n and the red cross raising some
hope that lives can be saved even from
besieged cities like mariopol but while
the guns momentarily fell silent in the
port city
fighting has raged along the
battlefields of eastern ukraine a
grinding russian offensive has forced
the few remaining residents in towns
like lehman to flee where we saw
volunteers risking their own lives to
save others
right after he left town a russian air
strike destroyed that railway bridge
leading out of town
it's part of a wider campaign for
russians trying to stop us and western
weapons from reaching ukrainian forces
fighting on these front lines
in another indication the wars extended
beyond these front lines to russian soil
explosions were reported in the russian
border town of belgorod where social
media video captured a military
installation on fire russian forces are
also being targeted on water this video
claims to show a ukrainian drone
destroying two high-speed patrol boats
in the black sea
exhausted ukrainian soldiers remain
outnumbered and outgunned and can only
hope america's heavy weapons get here
before the russian military does
now president putin is determined to
take over the entire donbass region that
includes this town russian
forces are advancing from the north and
the south threatening to trap both
ukrainian soldiers and civilians alike
nate
charlie dagetta in ukraine thank you